intriguing information yesterday shared
by ravens quarterback lamar jackson the
2019 nfl mvp with rich eisen
listened to what he had to say about
whether and to what extent the ravens
offense
is a little too predictable
just from the eye test it looks like
things aren't coming as easy
for you this year is that a safe way to
look at it that thing
i feel um you know it's a lot of it's a
lot of schemes you know we're going to
get defenses um they calling out our
plea stuff like that like they know what
we're doing so
a lot of that you know sometimes you
know stuff won't go our way if they beat
us to the punch so you're hearing on the
other side of the line of scrimmage the
defense calling out your place yeah they
definitely do like run stuff like that
watch out for this watch out for that
sometimes that's what's going on
so how do you how do you combat that
lamar so we i guess we're going to have
time and let coach you know let us know
what he sees upstairs
and we just go from there
that's troubling isn't it to hear
that a quarterback is
perceiving and realizing that defensive
players know what's coming once you know
what's coming more than half the battle
is won as a defensive player it's that
guesswork that happens before the snap
that gives the offense its edge well
listen there's you know there's some of
that that goes on in the nfl football
game you know i think there's a lot
there's a lot too to talk about this to
unpack this a little bit i mean the
first thing is this hey the offense last
year took the nfl by storm it took the
nfl by storm so
you know what do people do when that
happens they all study it
then
once they all study it especially the
teams that know they got baltimore on
the schedule they're all taking a week
going wait this guy how we gonna tackle
this damn guy and these big linemen he's
gotten from him so everybody's doing a
little due diligence anyways then you
know the other aspect of this too mike
is you know teams with running
quarterbacks that have any mobility
are running some of the plays that lamar
jackson
and company run so now you know the the
repercussions of that is their defense
gets to practice against it in practice
now right so there's all those aspects
and then
you know added on to it hey let's not
forget it's still the number one run
offense in football and they do that uh
but i will say to his point like because
i went back and watched patriots ravens
from last year a little bit yesterday
because that's our sunday night game
and
the ravens offense is not as creative as
it was last year not even in the run
game i don't know why i don't feel like
there's as many different formations and
has moved the movement's not quite the
same way
but nonetheless it's still a really good
run game i mean it really is now the
pass game does not help them and because
they're a run first team and teams are
always worried about that and clued into
this and all those type of things you
know and the pass game doesn't scare
anybody that you know in both emboldens
those linebackers and things to call out
runs and be all of that stuff even more
mike so yeah they're gonna have to do
some self-scouting it's something i said
on the pod the other day where they're
gonna have to reevaluate how they attack
a little bit because i'm sure there are
teams on to a little bit of their
tendencies
and i i know that that that's just one
of the many things that coaches have to
worry about as they get ready for a game
they're studying the opposing defense
but the best organizations and the
ravens are one of the best organizations
that's what makes this surprising the
best organizations will have coaches in
place
whose job primarily if not exclusively
is
to engage in that self scouting to stay
a step ahead of the opposing defense and
ensure that the offense doesn't have
those tendencies and tells that can be
picked up in film study and allow a
defense to call out plays and say this
is what's coming next that's what's
coming next and you know i i also can't
help but wonder
just the fact that lamar jackson pointed
it out and yeah look it just kind of
came up casually but i can't help but
wonder whether or not defenses think
that that rattles him a little bit
to hear that that some of it is common
to football that you're always going to
have before the play
watch that go here no no different than
52 is the mic right you're going to have
the defense yelling to each other and
trying to get guys lined up based upon
what they see to the extent that that's
registering with lamar jackson and he
mentions it spontaneously during an
interview maybe maybe they're doing it
in part because that's part of this game
of getting inside of his head before the
snap is there anything to that i i don't
know about that i will say to the to the
point though that maybe you know i i
like to what you're saying
where it does go on
like it goes on and you know when not
that i played a ton of quarterback in
the nfl but even in you know our best
games you still had middle linebackers
were going hey there we go watch that
guard he looks like he's gonna pull or
do those things you know i think the
reason he's bringing it up is because i
i he he's probably hearing it more this
year and i think he's probably he's
probably a little astounded by it at
times where you know
yeah there's probably some tells certain
formations personnels
and you know all the
all the tricks about what people look at
as far as linemen alignment of guards
when they're pulling and doing all those
things so i bet you that's a little
shocking to him i'll say this though too
mike off of that man i had a lot of
times where
i i heard linebackers and people call
plays out and i went man we're gonna see
how this works right like i'm too late
in the snap count i'm going to say set
hut here we go
too late guys called out to play but
then i give the ball the running back
and turn around and damn it's a 15-yard
gain so that doesn't always mean the
play won't be successful and then i
think the other thing too is baltimore's
one of those teams mike that i don't
know if they give a damn sometimes if
you know what play they're gonna run i
think they just go no we're better we're
bigger we're more physical we're coached
well
and so what you know what's coming you
know i i don't know if they're always
looking for the curveball to self-scout
themselves right if they run like two
guards pulling to the right and he hands
it off and hands it off and hands it off
what they do sometimes is just the same
play but they go hey let's keep him
honest lamar keep it out the back door
so it's the same look but you know the
defense can't play it the same way
because oh wait we got to worry about
that damn quarterback who's got three
rockets up his butt going around the
edge and that's a little how they do
that too so um there's a lot to these
subjects i'm not concerned about it but
i have noticed that they're not maybe
as creative this year as last year
and you're absolutely right some teams
are so good it doesn't matter if the
defense knows what they're going to do
and also as it relates to spotting what
an offense is doing
part of it is alignment
part of it is
all it takes is one guy exactly that's
right giving that that message based on
how he lines up for a pass play how he
lines up for a run play 100 and that's
what and that's what offenses need to be
studying
in their own film they need to be
looking for the same things that the
defense looks for chris spielman was on
this program
early on before you joined us and i was
fascinated by his tales of what he finds
in film what he looked for in film
it's anything and it's everything and
it's alignment and it's every
bit of body language
every player anything and everything and
you see those tendencies develop and
that's what helps you crack the code on
what's coming but as you said sometimes
it doesn't matter it doesn't always
matter
no it doesn't still can't stop it no it
does it doesn't always matter but hey
i'll say i played the baltimore ravens
the opening game of 2006
and
i don't know
ray lewis was called out every other run
play we played that day to speak to like
a guy like chris spielman who could you
know oh this guy he turns his butt like
three degrees when he wants to pull and
i know that's when he's pulling or he
cheats this foot back a little bit when
he wants to pull the other way to give
himself an advantage
he called some plays out of that day and
i remember just going oh my gosh poor
michael pittman i'm about to hit him the
ball and ray lewis going to crush him i
don't know what else to say but yeah he
was all over it and he was all over it
and i know and i don't know exactly but
it was through the offensive lineman
alignments yeah we did plays that we
know we liked in certain formations and
personnels and that of course gets them
to start thinking
but he was calling out guys like he's
gonna pull he's gonna like he knew and
that was scary him and zach thomas i'll
say that two guys zach thomas legend
down there in miami they called more
damn plays out i i sometimes was like
does he have the damn quarterback thing
in his ear too is he hearing gruden call
to play i mean they were amazing at it
and it's funny when you mention the
ravens it reminds me of something i
noticed years ago randy moss's rookie
season the vikings played in baltimore
went to the game
when the play was coming to randy moss
he sprinted out of the huddle
when randy moss wasn't involved in the
play jogging he walked to the line of
scrimmage and it was obvious it was so
obvious now with a guy like randy moss
it doesn't matter right it doesn't
matter it doesn't but the other 10 guys
the other 10 guys probably would have
preferred yeah they need to have the
signal right that you can focus on the
other guys and not focus on randy moss
this play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports